the trailer for ghostbusters afterlife
is finally dropped and prepare for a
shock
some fans on the internet aren't happy
apparently the spots fairly straight
faced serious tone and mostly youthful
cast which includes stranger things
start thin wolfhard has a vocal minority
of viewers convinced that the new flick
will be nothing more than a lowly ripoff
of the hit Netflix series a handful of
said fans took the Twitter to voice
their displeasure while it's true that
the spot is pretty restrained forgoing
goofy humor in favor of some table
setting for the flicks story one would
be forgiven for thinking that the
absolutely insane number of callbacks to
be original classic Ghostbusters movies
contained therein would have been enough
to make any fan grin like Slimer with a
mouth full of hot dogs one would need to
have forgotten the nature of the
Internet however to think that's true
there will always be a certain subset of
fans who won't be happy with any
interpretation of any beloved property
no matter what and the duly elected
representatives of this subset were on
Twitter in full force this week most of
their missives were shortened to the
point one Twitter user stated bluntly
the new Ghostbusters movie is gonna be a
stranger things rip off another peeved
user on the other hand snark just watch
the new stranger things season trailer
and it's called Ghostbusters for some
reason meanwhile another earth tweeter
complained quote why does the new
Ghostbusters look like a ripoff of
stranger things when they had that shot
of the two kids walking down the road I
laughed out loud the same user later
tweeted quote maybe we shouldn't be
making any more Ghostbusters movies ever
geez who are these folks some are people
who just want attention others just
nutballs who come in off the street we
kid we kid anyway while some Twitter
users were obviously displeased other
advance the same opinion but weren't
quite so harsh this person wrote
stranger things plus Ghostbusters is
probably a smart play but the trailer
death didn't feel like Ghostbusters
meanwhile this guy actually seemed kind
of pumped writing totally thought this
was going to be a fan film when I
clicked on it I am in for stranger
things Ghostbuster edition it's worth
noting that while stranger things might
have done it best in recent years the
Netflix phenomenon did not invent the
plot hook of children and or teenagers
facing off with supernatural danger one
could even make the case that
Stephen King's novel it which heavily
inspired stranger things did that it's
also worth noting that anything be it a
film or a show featuring bin wolfhard
thrust into a spooky supernatural
situation is going to feel like stranger
things if only because it was the retro
sci-fi horror series that rocketed him
into the public eye on another note all
of those incredibly fans services small
details in the Ghostbusters afterlife
trailer can be seen as a firm
declaration of intent on the part of
director Jason Reitman and co-director
Gil Kenan they intend to honor the
original story and refer early and often
to its characters and events but this is
their film and they're going to tell
their own story
personally we find that story which
appears to involve the family of the
deceased Egon Spengler uncovering a
terrible secret in small town in which
dear old grandpa owned an old farmhouse
to be a stroke of genius and if we're
being honest we also think it's a no
brainer to lean on a young cast as
pointed out by Paul Rudd's character in
the spud there hasn't been a ghost
sighting in 30 years and the original
Ghostbusters of course haven't been
active during that entire period
treating the activities of that crew as
half forgotten legend which our young
heroes must be filled in on before they
can truly appreciate what they're up
against is an inspired plot device one
that sounds a heck of a lot more
interesting than simply throwing the
original cast of ghostbusters all in
their 70s at this point back into their
costumes for one more nostalgic beat for
beat go-round don't get us wrong it's
awesome that the original cast is
involved and we hope their involvement
will be significant and they won't be
simply relegated to glorified cameos but
come on guys if we really want Sony to
show us everything in the first trailer
for the movie
we're actually glad the studio didn't
spill all of their narrative beans in
this spot and frankly we hope they show
similar restraint when they inevitably
give us the second and third trailers
that will likely perceive two movies
you can bet that we'll be first in line
when Ghostbusters afterlife drops on
July 10th 2020 and also that will be
here to offer our extra special blend of
expert analysis check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
or coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one